[MARGOLIS] As a bedside nurse, as an administrator, as a chief nursing officer, as a CEO,
I've had  wonderful mentors, and I've had wonderful opportunities to learn.
And I think that's how I got here -- on the shoulders of others.
who were willing to help me and who were willing to teach me.
[WOODYATT] In addition to being a strong leader and a strong visionary,
at the core, Marilyn is a nurse.
And I think that's what makes her such a great leader.
[MARGOLIS] Who wouldn't want to work at a place where the CEO is a nurse?
[WOODYATT] I chose nursing as a career because I wanted a career that was not only challenging,
but it was a career that was rewarding at the same time.
I also wanted a career that allowed me to be innovative
and allowed me to constantly be thinking about new ways of doing things better for patient care.
It's a universal career. It's a career that's accepted everywhere around the globe.
[MARGOLIS] With Corey, he's enthusiastic, he is a collaborator, he's a great communicator.
He's a thinker. He wants to improve things.
[WOODYATT] I decided to become an emergency room nurse because I wanted something that challenge me.
And I wanted a profession that would force me to think critically.
[MARGOLIS] I hope that really what defines us is our compassion,
is our love of what we do, and the love of the patients.
[WOODYATT] There's really nothing more rewarding than a patient telling you that they appreciate your time,
that you were a good listener, and that they just needed someone to speak to, and you were there for them.